[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we'll be discussing something
that has a very different function in
the muggle world I am of course talking
about broomsticks where a muggle may see
this as a tool which they dread taking
out of the closet
a wizard sees an opportunity to fly now
we hear a few different brooms
name-dropped throughout the books and
films most notably in one of the
beginning sequences of the Philosopher's
Stone
when Hagrid first takes Harry to Diagon
Alley when they walk past the broom shop
children are gawking at a broom through
the window whoa look at it the new
Nimbus 2000 Harry overhears as he walks
by so the Nimbus 2000 was the hot broom
of the time but as the books and films
progressed we also hear of newer faster
updated brooms the fire bolt was
released in 1993 and it superseded the
Nimbus 2000 as the best broom around
Harry eventually gets one as a gift from
his Godfather serious when his Nimbus
2000 is snapped but a whomping willow so
with all of these brooms being
name-dropped left and right it made me
wonder how many types of brooms are
there it turns out that between the
harry potter and fantastic beast series
there are a whopping 22 different broom
types and makes I say types and makes
and not brooms specifically because
there are many iterations of brooms like
the Nimbus and the comet the video would
be far too long if I break down that far
into the minutiae the exception to this
rule would apply to companies that only
made one broom in which case I will
mention this specific broom without
further ado here the 22 broomstick types
and makes number one toy brooms toy
brooms are small brooms marketed at
young witches and wizards they can lift
about two feet off of the ground Harry
actually received a toy broomstick from
his Godfather Sirius on his first
birthday
number two blue bottle the blue bottle
is a safe reliable broom stick that is
designed for family use a solution for
the whole family it also has a built-in
ante burglar puzzle
number three silver arrow the silver
arrow was the fire bolt of its time and
is considered to be the forerunner of
the modern racing broom on the silver
arrow you can reach speeds of up to 70
miles per hour
rollin de hooch who taught Harry to fly
at Hogwarts learned on a Silver Arrow
and before shooting star the shooting
star was first made in 1955 and was
marketed as the cheapest racing broom on
the market ron weasley had a shooting
star before he upgraded to a clean sweep
11 in more modern times shooting star is
very standard and Hogwarts actually has
supply of them that students use for
flying lessons number 5
clean sweep clean sweep brooms have been
released in a number of iterations most
notably the clean sweep 1 2 3 5 6 7 and
11 clean sweeps are a household name and
are produced by the clean sweep
broom company which was founded in 1926
the clean sweep is primarily used for
Quidditch and is one of the first brooms
to be designed specifically for sports
number 6 comet comet brooms are another
household name and also come in a number
of iterations most notably the comet to
140 180 to 20 to 60 and 290 comets
brooms are produced by comets training
company which was founded in 1929 it was
the first broom to include the Horton
Keach breaking charm which would help
Quidditch players stop more precisely
the comet broom started with Edition
number 140 because it took them 140
tries to get the first one right number
7 Nimbus Nimbus brooms are created by
Nimbus Racing broom company which was
founded in 1967 the brooms are marketed
toward Quidditch players and they are
very fast and versatile brooms Nimbus
created different brooms most notably
the Nimbus 1000 1001 1500 1700 2001 and
of course 2000 Nimbus brooms are very
expensive and Harry received one as a
gift from a carnival when he joins the
Gryffindor Quidditch team number eight
five bolts
fire bolts are exceptionally well made
and lightning fast broomsticks they're
capable of achieving speeds upwards of
150 miles per hour and have a ton of
special features including the
unbreakable
breaking charm and goblin made iron work
helping with power and stability the
broom is produced by broom maker
Randolph spud Moore in 1993 Harry saw a
fire bolt in the window of quality
Quidditch supplies before his third year
and wanted one but never bought it for
himself and received one as a gift from
Sirius at Christmas in 1993 number nine
Thunderbolt the Thunderbolt was the main
competitor to the fireball supreme which
was the fastest model of the fireball
broom the Thunderbolt was made in 2014
and was used by the Nigerian national
Quidditch team the fireball supreme
proved to be the Thunderbolt superior as
the Thunderbolt smashed to pieces after
being hit by a pleasure this is
something that all brooms should be able
to endure number 10 airwave gold the
airwave gold was a broom manufactured in
the 1990s and was featured on a magazine
cover in the half-blood prince film
adaptation the airwave gold is used
primarily for racing and is commonly
compared to the turbo xxx which we learn
about later in the video
number 11 australian fly about the
australian fly bat was a racing broom
used by the Australian national
Quidditch team it was first produced in
Australia in 1994 number 12 Oakes after
79 the oak shaft 79 was a broom designed
by broom maker Elias Grimstone in 1879
the 79 in its name comes from the year
that it was built due to its age the oak
shaft is not particularly agile when
compared with more modern brooms but it
is appreciated as a vintage piece number
13 siberian era the siberian aero was a
racing room used by the siberian
national Quidditch team they were
produced for the 420 second Quidditch
World Cup number 14
star sweeper star sweepers were
provements used by the American national
Quidditch team they were exceptional
broomsticks that were produced for the
420 second Quidditch World Cup number 15
Mak Tony broomsticks McCarney
broomsticks are first mentioned in a
newspaper seen in the fantastic beasts
film their slogan was fly higher than
the Scottish Highlands they were
generally used broomsticks made of
Hibernian wood number 16 fan bus station
wagon the fan bus station wagon is my
favorite broom and is mentioned in the
order
the Phoenix Film the fan bus station
wagon was much longer than an average
broom and was designed to accommodate
family of six it was actually produced
by Nimbus brooms but served a much
different purpose than their traditional
broom stick number 17 tinder blasts the
tinder blast was a broom created by Ella
B and spud more in 1940 it was a loose
competitor to the clean sweeps and
comets at the time though it could not
necessarily keep up with them it was a
highly dependable broom number 18
Transylvanian Bob the Transylvanian Bob
was a racing room created for the
Transylvanian National Quidditch team
number 19 turbo XXX the turbo XXX was a
racing broom manufactured in the 1990s
it was commonly compared to the air way
of gold which was featured in a copy of
seeker weekly in 1996 number 20 Twitter
90 the Twitter 90 was created by flight
and Barker in 1990 it was designed
primarily for Quidditch and its creators
felt that it would replace the Nimbus as
the market leader in broomsticks
however the Twitter didn't take off
quite as well as the Nimbus as it was
known to warp at high speeds number 21
for a pee dose the virap Eidos were
brooms used for the Brazilian national
Quidditch team in the 420 2nd Quidditch
World Cup and lastly number 22 the Yazoo
Russia yachiru she's were brooms used by
the Japanese national Quidditch team in
the 420 2nd Quidditch World Cup with all
of the above brooms mentioned I hope
that gives you a little bit of insight
into the world of broomsticks and
broomstick makers I know that lots of
brooms are name dropped throughout the
books and films but without an overview
like this it's hard to say how they
compare to others I think that without
question the fire bolt supreme reigns
supreme and that's it for this video I
hope you enjoyed it if you have any
questions about broomsticks let me know
down below also what's your favourite
broomstick until next time
your hairy
[Music]